le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
à partir d'un certain âge ou lorsqu'on
est atteint par la maladie les activités
de la vie quotidienne peuvent devenir de
plus en plus difficile des choses
simples comme se faire à manger ou
nettoyer sa maison deviennent compliqués
voire impossible à faire la solution
serait de prendre une femme de ménage ou
une aide ménagère mais dans la majorité
des cas les retraites sont insuffisantes
pour assumer une telle dépense c'est une
situation très embarrassante pour une
partie des personnes à la retraite alors
qu'ils proposent des solutions à cette
situation délicate on en parle
maintenant d'un lien social
madame dambreville vit à saint denis
comme beaucoup de personnes de son âge
madame dambreville vit seule dans son
appartement un appartement qu'elle
essaie d'entretenir du mieux qu'elle
peut
mais à son âge les choses simples de la
vie quotidienne sont parfois difficiles
à exécuter passer le balai faire la
vaisselle s'occuper de son linge sont
devenus des tâches très pénible pour
elle une situation qu'elle est bien
obligé d'accepter
madame dambreville a toujours réussi à
assumer sa famille et ses enfants
aujourd'hui diminué à cause de son âge
elle a dû voir la vie d'une autre façon
et accepter les faits il ya quelques
temps madame dambreville s'est retrouvé
dans une impasse elle ne pouvait plus
assumer seul son appartement et n'avait
pas les moyens de s'offrir une femme de
ménage ou une aide ménagère elle c'était
difficile de mon âge de fer termina je
n'arrivais plus à ma fille venait
m'aider mawâzine venez m'aider mais
il fallait quelqu'un et moi je
et c'est là qu'on a fait des démarches
ma fille
la fille de madame dambreville a rempli
le dossier ce qui a permis à sa maman
d'avoir une aide à domicile une équipe
du conseil général est venu au domicile
de madame dambreville et à évaluer les
besoins depuis maintenant un an et demi
aline vient chez madame dambreville 40
heures par mois
grand soulagement et une aide efficace
pour le maintien de l'appartement mais
allen est là elle vient tous les matins
elle fait le mieux
les choses essentielles le lille
on y attend elle peut pas refaire le
grand ménage et puis elle vient alors
deux fois par deux après midi par
semaine pas faire un grand ménage
grâce aux aides du conseil général
madame dambreville peut bénéficier des
services de aline cette aide lui permet
d'avoir un appartement propre tout le
temps mais la présence régulière d'aline
est bien plus qu'une aide ménagère
chaque jour c'est un moment de solitude
en moins pour madame dambreville car
malheureusement comme pour beaucoup de
personnes de son âge les compagnies sont
rares et la solitude pèse beaucoup et
quand on est seul que reprocher les
enfants
sont pris mais je me retrouve pas
heureusement que j'ai fais vraiment sauf
que justement que la maintenant j'ai ma
fille qui était malade et que
malheureusement que j'ai vu à l'hymne
parce que c'est céline dion deng les
gentille serviable
vraiment une bonne personne sait pas si
tout le monde est pareil mais une bonne
personne
pour aline son métier va bien au delà
des fonctions du ménage elle est bien
consciente que sa présence régulière
aide et soutient madame dambreville
aussi très important de l'occuper de ces
personnes qui sont souvent le plus
souvent seul à en bâtir et
en plus apporté à part le ménage faire
les travaux quotidiens
apporter mon soutien moral
certaines personnes âgées n'ont pas ce
privilège d'être bien entouré d'avoir
des personnes qui prennent soin d'elle
donc je pour moi c'est très vilain ge
grâce aux aides mises en place par le
conseil général
2500 personnes âgées bénéficient d'un
soutien physique et morale au quotidien
le département tient à ce que le
troisième âge ne se sentent pas
abandonnés et puisse continuer à nous
transmettre les valeurs de la réunion
pour bien vieillir il faut effectivement
être en bonne santé la préserver est
aussi pouvoir se faire aider quand on
n'arrive plus à accomplir les tâches de
la vie 106 millions d'euros sont
consacrés chaque année par le conseil
général et aux aides à domicile à l'aide
ménagère tout ce que vous percevez comme
aide s'est payé par le conseil général
même quand c'est la mairie qui vous
envoie quelqu'un je me suis rendu compte
qu'il y avait des inégalités entre les
traitements de demandes entre les
différentes structures et aussi des
inégalités du service rendu pour toutes
ces personnes âgées c'est pour cela que
je lance des contrôles rapidement dans
les mois qui viennent pour remettre à
plat l'aide ménagère l'aide à domicile
comme l'allocation personnalisée à
l'autonomie pour que nos vieilles
personnes dépendantes soient mieux
accompagnés et qu'on puisse leur donner
à ce t'as quoi elles ont droit parfois
ça n'est pas encore le cas en soutenant
les personnes âgées le conseil général
leur permet de vivre décemment quel que
soit leur niveau de revenu loin d'être
une charge cette dépense est un
investissement car elle permet de
renforcer les liens intergénérationnels
et de préserver nos valeurs et notre
vivre ensemble qui font la richesse de
la réunion
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais